talk about best friend because that's a
song that
uh got you nominated for a Grammy
um big record
was uh was like the the chemistry what
you and Doge are just like off the rip
just
suit was it like an easy record to make
because she seems like super dope like I
mean I've hung out with her she's cool
as [ __ ] we kind of have the same kind of
humor but how was like the creative
process making that record
so I'm at dojo in London so I didn't
even know she was from LA
okay yeah so when I initially met her it
was she was hella cool but I always
thought that she was from London so when
I found out she was in LA like working
with her was a lot more easier right and
when I had the best friend record I just
thought that we'd sound you know good
together and that's someone like
I may not kick it with her but I [ __ ]
with her and I feel like for a record
like that you gotta really have a
friendship with like the person you're
making it with that's not the type of
record you just add somebody on to it I
mean it's called best friend yeah you
want to actually be friends with the
person you make this happen absolutely
yeah that's fair who's your actual best
friend in real life though
um the microphone the microphone well
that was a political answer so whoever
no but is it your friend's Circle don't
get offended no when you think of like a
best friend I'm at the studio all the
time but I do got some dope homegirls
Fifi Stephanie Khadijah Stephanie put
them on yeah you got two Stephanies damn
I said Stephanie's wife I might say oh I
hope I'm not forgetting nobody you have
an animal or something I do want to get
a um a pet
yeah
what kind of like a joke just don't get
a Frenchie I'm not more of like a pit
bull kind of girl yeah I just feel like
like we get it you got a French Bullet
by the way I got a French Bulldog
you do yes what's the French bulldog's
name his name is Larry Larry yeah okay I
have a dog named Larry and then I have a
Pomeranian named Lebowski The Big
Lebowski my favorite movie
behind you
boom oh wow Have You Ever Seen The Big
Lebowski no I've never seen it with Jeff
Bridges well it's about this dude is it
in French no no that's just the French
movie poster for it
okay so the Big Lebowski is about a
loser who lives in L.A
um I'm gonna watch him take a picture of
it yo yeah you got to watch it
and so
it starts they pretty much there's a
this guy's name is Jeff Lebowski there's
another Jeff Lebowski in La that's like
a millionaire that owes these guys a
bunch of money so these guys show up to
the poor Jeff lebowski's house and they
beat the [ __ ] out of him and they piss
all over his rug
thinking that he's the guy who owes the
money but then they realize they look
around and they're like wait a minute
isn't this guy supposed to be rich he
lives in this piece of [ __ ] apartment
and so then they just leave
so this guy loved his rug so much that
he rolls the rug up and he he finds the
millionaire Jeff Lebowski and he brings
the rug to his house and he says yo man
they were looking for you they pissed on
my rug I need a new rug and that's just
and then it just is it's just a wild
wild [ __ ] movie oh it sounds like a
it's hilarious like a um like a step
brothers type of like a super bad it's
better than that for sure really yeah
but okay I mean it's the best movie ever
okay number one it's the greatest of all
time what's your favorite movie oh
I don't know
you don't know no it depends on my mood
well what are your favorite like give me
three movies you really really like that
I really really like yeah I like oh I
love pans Labyrinth oh that's a heater I
love that one
um
I like Scarface
okay like that's a type of movie like
I'll just put on like I'm not watching
it but because I watched it so much it
just makes me feel like I'm at home yep
um
and I like zootopia